all right people join in this live
stream we are talking about code
assistance fourth language um and let's
take a look what are we starting off so
as a background to a lot of code
assistance stuff there will be a
discussion about parsing and the
underlying linting technology also that
I think also needs design reviewed you
know proper names and have you guys
looked at chris cooley stuff about
estie's for external languages the code
analysis Pacolet yes
yeah that's it's a little bit different
because that's very very specific to C
and C++ and there's yeah I mean it's
it's just it's a different beast well
what do we learn from it I'm not sure
because so we're also using I pretended
we've in the compiler group we're using
clang link as the way of getting access
to clang and its parser and everything
so it's just yeah I mean we have
different well that's what I think
that's what Chris used is clang well but
not I mean but he didn't oh yeah yeah
but I mean we're not using that we're
using collect we're using another you
know we're using a different layer on
top of clang he's already worked on
something very close to this it will be
really useful to understand what he's
done okay but let's let's take a look at
what you have here okay all right this
is going to be a complicated design
problem sure yeah I mean it also relates
to the way of tagging text with text
elements and so on
all right okay let me just understand
the structure of this meeting so we've
got some ast representation and the
question how that should work
yeah this isn't even close I mean
there's a lot of work to be done for
this I mean it may only not be user
exposed which means it may or may not be
worth you know huge design effort and we
may not be ready to be huge design
effort you know and it may not be
necessary for what we're trying to
achieve well I know that this is yeah
big wall of text imposing but the
functionality it's largely all here it's
a question I was wondering about this
meeting it could be a question of going
over names of things oh look look look
look
yeah the other thing you haven't done is
to look at how this relates to the tree
project we've got a whole project about
you know analysis of trees which
obviously these are right and so those
have a whole bunch of things to do it
that's Hosea's project maybe we can see
if you can join this meeting can can we
find out if Jose and or chris cooley can
join this meeting to do that please
yeah well just as an overview yeah if
you keep so just about parsing which we
may not even really need to talk about
and then linting that I'm more
interested in getting your opinions on
and so since okay what have you done so
far with the what's happened with the
line formatting stuff is that what's
part of this so is it something
different you know that that's this but
so as a preface at the very top I don't
want to get into you know the specifics
of you know how to break lines and
everything I wanted to be talking about
the inputs and outputs and names of
thing of functions that would be exposed
to users don't go to see what they do
before we have any idea what that what
those are going to be I mean okay so
let's take a look here
okay so we already have multiple pauses
so this is another Pazza that correct or
is this a positive that's going to use
the same front end as some existing
causa no it's it's it's another parser
it's not a good idea well I think it is
I mean I might be biased but so I have
been spending a lot of time on it and
this more so Xan both the kernel and the
front end parsers have has been hardened
and bullet proved and tested to a
greater extent and has actually helped
find bugs in both the kernel and the
front-end parsers by comparing you know
what they both do separately a foe has
this puzzle relative to those ones well
so this a lot of this is in top level
right now and so speed I don't even want
to talk about because you don't compare
the speeds yet but I'm slowly moving
more and more stuff to native code where
when we could talk about speed but a lot
of this is on top level and I mean
there's just no comparison of speed
right now okay what you're doing sorry
that's not the most relevant thing for
what you're trying to do probably yeah
okay so that the output from this is an
ast what's the idea of that
how would that I mean are you imagining
that one day this becomes the standard
puzzle that we use or what well yes but
not this output because you know I mean
parsing directly to expressions is what
is needed obviously for you know
replacing anything extant parser but
this serves a purpose for users wanting
to build their own tools that we you
know yeah it is a problem of reinventing
the wheel you know many times many
different parsers but the advantage of
this is that this is all written in
higher-level C++ modern code and
top-level code that benefits from you
know just being newer and cleaner and I
had nine goals sorry is it
complete puzzle it is absolutely
complete yes no okay all closed you
multibyte unicode and it deals with all
that stuff it deals in less this has
features that are hard to add to the
other parses that we want so if we want
a profiler or a coverage tool this
parser is a good thing maybe to improve
the debugger this this parser is a
better way to implement things like that
it's more flexible and easier to extend
and those are things we want and so it's
tricky so for example if you're saying
backslash : you know to give the parser
an actual backslash : you know making
sure to escape the backslash you know
into the string so but but ya know you
can you can feed it absolutely anything
even syntactically incorrect code and it
will return something intelligible like
if you just evaluate that right now
something comes back you know I mean
various things saying errors here and
there but you know so again no it is it
is absolutely a complete parser okay so
how would I turn that into an expression
so yeah that's one of the questions that
I wanted to address today of what those
functions would even be called right now
you you could say to full form string of
ast to get a string the string back I
mean you know but so I don't want to
string I want some expression yeah so
the question is so I have these
functions parse Turing and parse file
and parse bytes for byte arrays and I
wanted to go over what the function
names one of the items below is what the
function name what the function should
be for parsing directly to expressions
and you know my my first iteration is
parse to expression and whether or not
that would be a good idea because then
well it's the same as to expression I
mean it's the same it's a method option
for two expression
sure that that yeah that could be enough
yes yeah that's a that's another way of
saying it yeah right so okay so how do i
display this in some way that I can
understand what's going on
yep that should work now there's a lot
of metadata the source information
clutters that up but you can definitely
see a structure well do you have some
visualization tool for this thing not
different than tree form now so probably
you need a version of this that is a
cleaner version which doesn't those
source tagging things that give string
positions and things yeah should be
elided in some way and yeah I think
it'll be useful to give this and I mean
I would model this on text structure
which has a way of displaying syntax
trees effectively for natural language
um okay okay
you know yep so all of this is fine so
it captures comments yes
so parse by itself what is supposed to
be abstract syntax and you will not see
a comment but if you said concrete
parsed string of that you will get the
comment back for example so if you just
cop if you evaluated that and then
replaced par string with concrete parse
time why you would want to keep the
comment and the generic ast parse well
that's not part of abstract syntax
that's what makes it abstract that's the
that's for example one of the
differences between concrete and
abstract syntax you I don't care what
it's called i it's the question how
people will actually use this well I
mean but if you want comments you would
say conch you know you would be dealing
with the lower level it's it's it's a
bit it's bit similar to those three
boxes before you do to you you convert
boxes to expression yeah boxes are not
valuable for therefore the kernels they
don't mean anything for the kernel
that's that's what a comment is Karen
doesn't care at all about candidates so
yeah I mean this is an illustration of
the difference between the two for
example and in whitespace and stuff like
that but that if you want to add
brackets in you know in a broken
expression you are interested in
comments and all the older scenes that
you know decorates your expression or
formatting or formatting definitely yeah
exactly but if you want to do profiling
you you you don't what you don't care
about that or debugging you don't care
about that so you need books you need
both talking romantically and so maybe
it's a question of which one does not
have the prefix maybe parsed by notice
time why this doesn't record its source
here the plus symbol was invented
what do you mean the plus symbol is
right there no that's not a
that's not the plus symbol okay where is
there's no heads where is the plus sign
in this whole thing
well this is this is the exact same
result on crates in the concrete no I I
understand that I want to know the
answer to you you're recording in this
case what the string source positions
were for those elements right for the
loser yes well as the string shows
position of the plus it's not the plus
signs source position is not in here
why like the comment it has been
abstracted away why I mean you know it
has a position right just like you know
that the one has a position you know the
plus has a position well the one the one
has the same representation in both you
know like that's a leaf node the plus
sign is not a leaf of the tree so and if
you care about the plus sign position
for example you would also want to do
concrete parsing I don't understand I
don't see why it's any less concrete
I mean will any less amenable to the
abstract so if you said par string of
you know head like symbol plus one comma
one you would get the exact same output
as what you have there it has the exact
same abstract I mean yeah square bracket
you know same output I mean different
source location no no right there
it says where the pluses pushed right
that well there is it doesn't say where
the bracket is no all right okay yeah if
you do concrete I understand I
understand I got it
yeah no I mean these are all good
differences between yeah right now the
open brackets are in there you see
what's group node the group of the
square brackets is what's group square
we don't have a symbol in the language
to represent the token of open square
bracket and close square bracket
I had to invent a symbol why don't we
use the string quotes Open bracket for
this we could we go that way we can
understand what's going on we could yeah
but it's just supposed to be will it
still be a thorn string maybe like token
of yes how is that relate to the way
that tokenization works for natural
language in text cases and text
structure I mean just different no
that's not good enough
I mean it's not good enough to just say
it's different you got to understand
what I mean so something like this is
very similar concept to what you're
doing
no but its text elements but it's we in
in natural language we have only one
words which is a word of what is written
we don't have a word of what is meant as
a structured state seems well we
actually do have some of that we have
noun phrases we have all kinds of things
like this we don't in terms of meaning
that is in terms of if you if you'd
rather have it as the word vectors which
is well no no we could perfectly well
have meaning for these things just like
we do if we parse to an entity we would
have meaning for that what text cases
does generates meaning from natural
language it's not as different as you
think okay let's keep going let me get
the bigger picture here yeah so
everything you were doing applies
equally if we were talking about so can
somebody pull up Chris Gulas version of
the ast system I mean I worked a bit on
the design of that does any didn't we
look at that design no I'm sure you
didn't
okay this was from 2016 did we manage to
find Chris and now we couldn't get them
I don't think he starts working for
another couple of hours but we do have
Jose okay that used to be a cool graph
there so okay we're looking Hosea
abstract syntax trees and I'm trying to
understand how they relate to our other
tree stuff so the tree element mechanism
do you have the design of the tree
element mechanism missing from so we
have an implementation in the x corner
so that's what I'm running here so what
would be an example of what I do try
expression tree of some expression
okay so this this is following text
element okay you guys can see why I
thought this was relevant
yes it's relevant okay so now if I want
to what is the nun doing there
so that's annotation for the final
leaves I see I see I see I see I see
yeah in the representation we also
distinguish their square notation from
their slightly rounded corners right
so in particular we should be able to
take one of these creatures here if I
say parsed string I should be able to
say expression tree lovely lovely now
what does that mean that it's saying I
see that's a note notes for associations
and lists I think we decided that it was
not worth having I see them right okay
that's actually quite useful um okay I
get it so that's that's the metadata of
the call node that's the that's the list
that of the contents of the call node
which is analogous to that element
thereof tree element right and in
element more like XML the metadata
occurs in the first argument in an
association the first argument right
make sense to people
yep Anton you understand yeah so what
you're doing here
the the difference here is in principle
one could represent this stuff in terms
of tree elements by just I mean it's a
very straightforward transformation
right because you would take these nodes
the name the type of node would be in
that Association that appears first and
then as would things like the source
metadata and so on right
am I correct I mean I don't know what
the intentions are with tree elements I
mean it sounds right yeah yeah well the
intention is to have a standardized
representation of trees in the system
well is that not well so if you scroll
up in the notebook that you're in right
now
no the with the tree with the plot you
were just in the other yeah did you
scroll up I mean the the argument to
expression tree that you gave f of G of
X and everything like that is a tree and
so I'm not 100% clear on what because
this is a this is essentially an
abstract this is a way of doing the kind
of thing you're doing this is think of
this as an abstract semantic tree okay
that term why did that not do anything
Oh what is not a string
right okay
okay I get it yeah and maybe they're
even completely isomorphic to each other
yeah well that's what I'm thinking yeah
thank you but I mean the real question
is you know we're going to have a bunch
of tools for manipulating trees in tree
you know in the tree element form and so
obviously those could be used you know a
lot of lot of you know manipulation
functions to do with tree substitution
and so on um and obviously one would
like to be able to reuse those things
yeah yeah um and also it provides a way
but I mean the the issue really is what
kinds of transformations are important
here all right let's keep going here um
so what you are effectively doing I mean
you know are we going to admit that the
thing is a tree probably I mean let's
imagine that what you were to generate
was a tree object here mm-hmm with with
all of your you know with everything
here but a lot of the stuff that's here
would turn into strings and so on that
would be part of the method ATAR of
essentially the tree element you know
let's imagine it was something like this
I mean I'm just there you know we're
basically all the metadata is is put
into that head Association and then it's
that's the same exact structure as this
yeah um so I mean essentially what this
would be is something which says you
know I don't know what um
AAS I don't know what it would say but
something like you know there'd be a
leaf there'd be a type arrow leaf etc
etc etc um is there something to reverse
expression tree yes I believe it's
called tree expression
holder's great so it'd be quite nice if
the output of PARs string if you did
tree expression on it it would give you
the expression can you get it back
wrapped in hold I'm sure you can I'm
sure you can I mean I mean obviously
yeah right I mean I mean do we have
something some kind of guide page of the
tree operations Jose a single step
that's writing one let me check okay
because I just think you know this is
what you're gonna need to edit past
trees and we've already got a bunch of
that functionality um but what I'm
concerned about is how to make the
patterns convenient I mean that's what
we tried to do on tree expression tree
oh absolutely it's it's a problem yeah
right well so that's what we were trying
to do with tree elements and that's why
we ended up with the structure we ended
up with is to be able to write the
patterns in a convenient way yeah I mean
the linter is a testament to how
cumbersome it is to do this kind of
thing okay to write patterns in this
language yeah okay well all right well
maybe the tree element will help all
right so I think I understand this and
there's another metaphor which is the
depth first and and breadth first scan
functions of grass
why because they navigate down through
these through trees and they're a mesh
well I'm just saying that that that's
another thing we have mm-hmm I mean
particularly breadth-first is a horrible
mess in terms of what action it takes
and each step and how it decides what to
do next
can you open a few eyes guide page cause
Driessen you
yeah this is the list of the symbols who
were planning okay so this this has
various kinds of this is useful I think
it could be really useful these these
are various ways of transforming to yeah
two graphs two expressions graphs and
this rules tree idea yeah so that was an
idea to input the tree faster than
writing what my quantity elements right
right and it's just a way of tree rules
it would just be a way of taking this
and transforming it to something that
just has a different structure which
might be more convenient for
manipulation similarly with with tree
graph right I mean there's node rule
list of sub nodes and this can be
iterated right tree replaced part and
tree path you know tree path is a
relevant thing here yeah that's a way of
specifying any position including
reference to like parents uncle where do
you supply that where does tree paths
get used in other functions like
replacement etc if so do you know if
it's efficient
I mean how house tree paths and things
like that implemented yeah this is not
particularly efficient but the way we
implemented now yes yes exactly so so
what Stephen is using right now some sub
top-level prototype and now the idea is
to make this work using the graph
functionality which has some already
some code to handle trees
nobody the concept of tree path and
parents and all of that is I have also
run into needing to you know to reify
that concept and so that's that's
interesting to be able to say that we
have something like tree path that does
represent that properly yeah and and
here we were fighting some particular
problem which was how to unify the
language of part expressions and the
language of extract of position
expressions yeah and that's why we
introduced a new head rather than having
just lists because there are three
different concepts in which we use lists
yeah okay so let's keep going I'm I'm
pretty pleased with this unification I
think this will work
you know this is really going to help on
both sides here so let's let's keep
going because this also presumably this
text element representation should be
easy to turn into a tree object um we
may already have a mechanism for that
for text structure yes I think some
particular expressions like text
elements and associations who are
already special in the system okay all
right okay okay so I understand so
there's a bunch of stuff to go back to
to what I mean you know I could imagine
that you are calling this something like
parse tree although I'm not sure that's
the right well yeah so the big one of
the big things I want to get out of you
if I can is your opinion about that what
the name of the function should be for
being given a string and returning these
you know these the node the big tree
know whatever the trees end up being
what the name of the function should I
understand I understand but that's that
that's a okay I get it but if it's going
to return a tree object I'm thinking I
mean I don't know whether I don't know
whether its string parse tree or
something like that I'm not sure but
though I don't know anything about yeah
adding tree but so I
No if parse by itself general there
might be a little parse is not gonna
work on its own but something which uses
the word parse will work Church but
let's take a look at Tim there might be
a file or there might be a bag I
understand what there could be yeah I
got it there's a byte array there's a
string there's a file I guess it same
thing with an import and it's not
obvious that those things
I mean import could perfectly well you
know when you import a dot WL file this
should be one of the elements of what
you can get out yeah yeah yeah um okay
but but now you've got tokenization
which is interesting and nice all right
let's take a look here before we loop
back to talking about these um so you've
got the abstract pooris you've got
concrete parse you've got tokenization
yeah these are the functions that exist
and what the question is what should be
one thing that I want it obviously there
could just be single functions for each
of these given but I get it I get it I'm
not ready to come back to that I want to
understand more about how this is used
sure okay so you've really managed to
run it on all these things that's great
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I have
more confidence in this than you know
other parser you do yeah okay all right
okay so that's parsing let's put a line
there yeah
so then with linting I'm already
prepared for not having the word lint I
understand I understand let's get let's
get let's take a look at the
functionality so you're returning so
this is something which there will be a
front-end UI element that kind of
invokes this yeah and this is more the
file report version of this correct well
I mean that's the point I'm you have a
line
it's something to do with the file well
I mean with strings you can have
multiple lines also sure you really do
want to report lines well not when it's
auto formatted well no note here there's
nothing about auto form it's just it's
taking that string that was given
there's no I understand but it's not
going to be if you're if you're Auto for
hunting everything's gonna be on line
one anyway that this is a detail there's
a deals it's not relevant so relevant
for in notebook type stuff except in
package files package notebooks okay so
this is the analog of a failure object
but for a lint output object is that
correct it is yes it is a question how
this does compared to things like
failure objects well it should have the
same structure I think it isn't the same
thing it shouldn't be a failure object
right have the same structure and it
does roughly I mean there's a tag
actually have the same structure
Association but yeah it doesn't I mean
it Tim okay so those are the functions
we can discuss about that formatting is
a little bit different because there are
functions analogous to the other things
we've been talking strings files and
bytes but with formatting there's a
question of what the output should be
when given a file because an expectation
is that you're modifying the file in
place that is different than strings and
byte arrays obviously being returned and
so just balancing that symmetry you know
well I don't think that I mean we don't
have a lot of things that return a file
in place I mean that's all that could be
another question okay maybe we don't
even want to sure yeah I think that's
what is clang format do is that you say
- I to mean in place
but by default if you don't supply the -
I it doesn't modify anything it returns
it to standard out right and then with
code assistance this is there's another
this is another beast where we're now
talking about interactivity but maybe we
don't even expose a function to do this
because it's pretty obscure to begin
with but if we did expose a function one
thing that I would want to make clear is
that this would not be specific to code
only and we could also be analyzing text
cells for example along with input cells
so what we do with the text so well so
if you evaluate if you create that
document there inside of that title if
you unform at that title cell there's an
invisible character that's an example
that you know can cause that's you know
the function application unicode
character that can come about from
copying and pasting is you know outside
and so you know you could also warn
about that sort of thing and so any
names that we come up with here well
John King code yeah yeah exactly I mean
similar yeah that means exactly yeah all
right okay okay so let me understand
then I mean our early target for this is
interactive code assistants in the front
end right so what we're talking about
here is the language level
representation of what's going on to
support that feature yes that users may
want to use right okay but but that
feature we're on track to have some
version of that feature yes
I'm afraid that you're implying for
version 12.1 no of course not okay yes
yes yes yes um Ethan our live stream is
commenting on lint as a function as
something parallel to wool from script
yeah I mean that's all of this stuff
that is you know language level is
absolutely applicable to um to those
command line things oh yeah stand-alone
tools are definitely a goal um okay
all right let's start from the beginning
again
okay have you talked to John folks about
the front end parser and also whatever
okay and what about yon and the pawza
for the cloud I mean just in very
abstract terms that's yet another puzzle
isn't it yes so they're actually three
well yes but I mean do we also count the
workbench do we I mean there know how
many pauses dude lots of them are you
asking how many we have deployed in
products or how many have floating
around the company even deployed in
products it would take some effort to
think of us how many and and you know it
you have to understand the parsers also
have different capabilities so you know
the front-end parser for example has a
capability that that none of the other
parsers import
has which is to robustly deal with
syntactically wrong stuff fine that is a
goal of this one that we're talking
right that say was being careful and say
none of the other parsers in production
yeah yeah I'm not excluding this does
the same thing as well okay oh yeah yeah
yeah that may very well be true yeah
you're right the as another example
going the other direction which is that
the notebook front end has a mini
Wolfram language parser for parsing
notebooks which does not you know it's
not capable of parsing the full Wolfram
language spec it's just a subset of the
spec just pausing the notebook source
code yes so the subset you know the
subset is is is fully correct but it's
you know far from complete so so the
first thing we need to understand is how
do we get from you know this is
basically it's the analog of to
expression i'm tend to think so this is
going to generate a so we have a string
here we have a byte array here
those are distinguishable by that data
types i would guess the file thing is
not is a file wrapper surely yeah yes
put the file wrapper I see okay fair
enough fair enough that's fine
okay um something is bothering me about
this no I guess not
I guess this is not taking I mean I
could imagine a held expression here
couldn't die not for parsing so there is
a question about why mean it's already
parsed well I understand that but she
might still want hmm there was a
question of
the lentor you know already parsed
expressions and I had a Evernote down
there if we want that parsing I don't
know if that if that matter if we want
that here or not okay but I mean so so
in a first approximation we could
imagine something like this well no
because you've already you definitely
can't ask for the concrete syntax of an
of an expression no no III got it I got
it ago then I'm talking about the second
argument structure and I'm talking about
you know by the time you're talking
about a concrete syntax tree and
aggregate syntax tree and abstract
syntax tree there are syntax trees you
know growing on trees so to speak yes
and and I don't think we want to start
off with a bunch of top-level functions
that represent those because we may want
to add variants to them etcetera
etcetera etcetera
so I mean this so I mean the way I would
think about it is if we hmm so let's
imagine that the objective is to create
a tree object of this kind now whether
it needs an outer wrapper I don't know I
mean in your version it doesn't have an
outer wrapper you just start with a
string node see what I'm saying well the
string node that's another question that
I had that is the outer wrapper a
question is what the outer wrappers
should be called well if it even needs
an out for alpha I mean in other words
it I think it does well I'm not sure it
does and I mean I think that as soon as
you introduce one of those things it
reduces interoperability well we we need
to be able to handle moult you know if
you said parse tree you know you said
one plus one newline two plus two and
then the question of whether there's an
outer wrapper
[Music]
it's some you might actually be parsing
more than one expression so what yeah I
understand that point so I mean to me
that's a top level in this tree and it's
got to have a named tree element but
again you know you've got let me make it
even more complicated let's say you're
pausing multiple expressions in multiple
cells then you gotta have yet another
kind of element you see what I'm selling
possibly yes definitely because you
don't want to you want to represent
those as a new line you know a sell a
new line whatever a cell group could get
really quite complicated I mean I think
another interesting question is to what
extent this representation can also
represent abstractly a notebook because
what we've got in I mean for example one
thing I don't think we thought about is
turning notebooks into trees see what
I'm saying
I say I don't think we thought about
that I was now thinking whether we can
represent itself like a tree in using
its own structure something like that
yeah I understand but I mean in terms of
but John I mean as we think about
modernizing notebook manipulation this
is another I mean what we've got in you
know the things that we're trying to do
with notebook manipulation are very
similar to the things we're trying to do
with parsed expression manipulation I
think does that make sense
not having been in the conversations
about Parsees freshmen if elation or
something aspirational as opposed to
stuff we already have well I'm talking
about a modernization of all of this
kind of notebook
what am I saying
you know replace this group in the
notebook with this type thing and so on
well so certainly one of the things
which we've been proceeding on you know
in an independent fashion in notebook
manipulation is you know youth the use
of you you IDs to be able to uniquely
identify parts of the notebook Dom which
is not what's happened here it could
happen here but it isn't what's happened
here right
Brenton I mean we're not using well no
well for it and for the UUID is to be
useful they have to be persistent in
some way I mean like you know II you
know britain's parser couldn't just
generate you you IDs because you know
it's you know they the you you IDs has
to have to have a you know a good long
lifetime well I understand that but the
point is that the the you IDs are
representing something that the user
sees on the screen that you can then
pick up parts of yes
okay all right let's go back here okay
so I think what we're what we're
realizing so let's imagine that we took
this representation and we basically are
using tree element for it yeah yeah okay
so let's take a look at what that means
so we've got um I mean I would use for
this for that source thing I mean what
is that isn't that string position what
is it in column I mean one line is not
interesting but once you have multiple
lines it becomes more interesting I see
okay well I mean obviously it needs a
name that is a little bit more
indicative of poor that's weird I mean I
think that there should be a way of just
getting the string position I think it's
going to be useful because otherwise you
have to you know to go back and
manipulate that I don't think the
obsession
multiline you know I think that should
be handled separately I think what you
should do since these lines are
independent I would have thought you
should split the lines first and then
have essentially a list of different
parse trees for the different lines
which means that then each line are
making sense
and then for example what you could do
this thing in the world to accidentally
have a you know an input that spans more
than one line though I mean know what I
mean so why do you need why do you care
about it's a mistake to do this with
with line numbers drink position don't
get me wrong
yeah but I mean I think then what one
one might want to do again let's let's
take a look all right so the basic idea
would be that you have a bunch of tree
elements and in the end you would say
something like type arrow leaf node
something like that and then you would
say string positions string position
arrows number number something like that
and then you might say well you might
have other decoration here you might
have other things that says you know
this is a I don't know what it is you
know some some kind of decoration about
that node yeah right
and then what you saw with the string
position there's already a question of
whether we in we say the end position is
inclusive or exclusive because it's very
very useful to count past the end of the
thing you're talking about but with
string position and functions that take
string positions they're always
inclusive and so there's already a
tension with you know if I just had a
single integer I understand so we may
have to have a different name for that
yes it might be useful that string take
just took that thing out
yes it would be useful string takes
should just work too you know to go from
this and I also think that my feeling
would be and again it may be it's too
inefficient to do this because it's to
be able to have the actual source but
this doesn't quite make sense that's why
yeah I understand so it can be string
position isn't the same as Brenton's
because this is starting four and one at
the beginning of the source
I understand which is well including
return characters whereas what Brenton
wants is each position is the position
in the line which is also totally useful
right there is people on a live stream
are asking for a formal spec for the
language which this should generate it
has been it's easier than ever but I
could a formal spec of the language
could definitely be generated yeah and
the code for this could be made
available right because this is we're
working with getting everything up on
github
yeah yep so so I think finally that
particular desire of having a formal
specification will be there even though
what it pauses into beyond the abstract
syntax tree may be a different story
yeah yeah okay but but now here okay so
we've got okay so we've got this and we
need we have some details to work out
with this I joke about a formal spec of
the language it's actually harder to
tokenize Wolfram language than it is to
parse tokens once you add it let's look
at tokenization for us it's actually
easy yeah let's I understand that for
the most part depending on what you mean
by token all right so this is the tree
version and there's some details here
about what I mean I would have imagined
[Music]
yeah that means isn't above that that's
aggregates node or something yes I think
there will be a good idea to have a
wrapper that goes above that um it's
still a tree element yes okay
so let's now take a look at your
tokenization okay so that is a separate
thing where where explain to me how I
mean in this tree you could imagine
putting tokens in here yes that's sort
of the point well also a linear
tokenization yes
that's all that I'm talking about but
you could as well represent in the tree
each of these nodes in the tree sir as
one big long yeah yeah well no no but I
mean a token here well let's take a look
at what your tokenization stuff does
scrolling scroll up scroll down tokens
yeah just a little bit further down and
then here right here yeah it's just
similar to parsing there's just
tokenizing returning flat lists of what
we've been talking about which is also
useful particularly for Timothy for
example for the machine learning people
to be able to grab this stuff quickly
where you're not dealing with the tree
structure directly but you know you're
still working with the Wolfram language
alright so I understand so this is this
is a flattened version of the tree more
or less yeah right so in the tree
manipulation system what do we have
that's along these lines this would be
effectively I think tree leaves D leaves
three Nazis three
try treelings am i correct
sure it's not tea leaves I'm sure of
that
um what are you talking about I I'm just
making a feeble joke good good I'm sure
what tree leaves would do I mean yes I
would have to see it I I assume it does
what we're expecting I would think so I
would think it might just makes a list
of the leaves of the tree in a in a
depth-first order there was a discussion
of whether to include their internal
notes or not I think we parameterize
this and I also I also imagine that we
should parameterize the order of the
trees of the tree walk yes um but I
think that's what that is well it's
important to realize you want the
performance of being able to tokenize
directly without having to go through
and spend a whole yeah abso well so the
obvious way to do that is to say parse
tree and instead of concrete syntax to
just say token lists him yeah for
example sure now okay with having that
different structure I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know okay I
mean it's still yeah right I mean I'm
not sure the name so this particular
thing would take in code correct it's
not going to take other stuff in is that
true are you meaning strings or what do
you mean no no no I mean I mean this is
going to take a string or file or byte
array that represents a piece of code or
it could take no no I well it could be
generalized to other things too
what's that
but but it's also it could also take the
content of a cell could it not it could
also take a notebook a fragment of a
notebook potentially yeah I mean we
could think of things like that but
those things have already been parsed in
some sense and it's a question of what
it is that we would be doing with it
then when our livestream wants to
tokenize let's see how do we tokenize do
we have that okay tokenized string okay
that looks like a pretty harmless
tokenization um front end goes wild with
it because it's considered a valid file
name oh my gosh well technically in the
documentation it says that square
brackets have to be balanced okay all
right well okay let's I'm sorry let's
come back out to this again okay because
I want to I want to make sure that we
have a path forward here that allows you
to actually you know redo the cosmetics
of this so that we're ready to you know
to roll forward so to speak and I think
Tony is the one who's now working on the
trees project right Jose yes with help
also from air force okay great
um so Brenton you should connect with
those people yeah okay um I think this
will be really good because this is a
you know it's a really use case for the
trees stuff um and okay I also would
like to suggest which I hadn't really
thought up before of taking notebooks
and turning them into trees and
understanding how that can be used in
the trees project that makes sense John
do you I mean is there an obvious is
there already existing code that
effectively does that in other words
you're making an abstract syntax tree
for a notebook otherwise known as a Dom
structure
well I guess I'm trying to figure out
how is that different from the
expression that we already have not very
different it might have some
conveniences in other words in this
collection of syntax trees yeah there
might be a normal tree that has some
other conveniences but the actual
notebook expression is hard to
understand as an actual tree I mean is a
tree but it's it's the front-ends format
of notebooks it's not quite what the
tree what the notebook structure
represents well I'm not sure about that
I mean it's a bunch of cell groups and
cells and so on anyway I think it were
useful to see it in this form because I
think that's a form in which it can be
manipulated all right but let's come
back over here so the other big
questions that you have I I will say by
the way just in terms of manipulation
the the single biggest annoyance in
manipulation is the fact that cell
groups are embedded in the notebook
expression and should be tree if I'd if
you want to do things like for example
you know remove a self you'll move
itself from one place to another you
might you might hope for is it just
being a flat list of things but it's
definitely not right so the correct
thing to do would be to have something
that says in this in this parse tree
mechanism something which will take a
notebook and parse it into an abstract
tree that has that annoyance removed and
then be able to write it back out again
in the same way that this can write back
out its syntax tree out as a string so
similarly you could write it back out as
a notebook and and by the way the Ethan
are live stream is asking about will
this replace the XML functionality
nightmare I would hope so that that's
also the goal of the trees project
[Music]
well probably we face here is that some
of these trees are going to be very
large so we started discussing how we
could interact with a tree expression
like opening a branch closing it things
that are whatever the we person
individually horizontally yes yeah
basically is one thing and that's
important and elision of trees like
collision of large graphs which is
another project to currently underway
right is you I mean a tree is much
easier to
elide than a graph because the tree you
just say below this node we're not going
to show it right and then you can you
know open that subtree and keep going
I'm making sense by the way various
people on a live stream are asking about
for hunt and we have a separate related
project on formatting this is a this is
a this is not the formatting branch this
is the symbolic representation branch
which feeds into the formatting branch
but this isn't the formatting branch
yeah just to be clear like all this
parsing stuff is used by the formatter
that I'm working on by the way this is
very nice stuff Brenton well done I mean
I'm just the yeah I'm okay let's talk
about the linter for a minute so the
issue is you've got a an expression or
no you've rather got a string and you're
going to produce commentary on the
string correct correct
okay and that commentary is actually a
very you know what you should produce is
a is potentially a very tagged object
that that a front-end can pick up and
use to attach to its actual
representation of the input correct I
don't know how this relates to front-end
interaction currently well okay so I'm
gonna say I think that what has to
happen is yes you have that message and
it's all very beautiful but the front
end has to know that message relates to
the thing that string position blah blah
blah
so that whatever front-end display
mechanism exists is able to attach it
correctly if it's a call-out you know if
we're talking about having if a BB in a
cell that we're talking about something
different no we're talking about no what
we're talking about here is you're
generating a collection of what the
underlying data for this is a collection
of information about you know it's
commentary on an abstract syntax tree
basically is that correct or is it
commentary on a string it's not just
abstract it's all levels because okay
fine it's its commentary on a concrete
syntax tree yeah that correct yep yeah
that's the way you want to think about
it yeah so in a sense what needs to
happen is that commentary just like
you've got a token list you want a
commentary list of some kind which
somehow you know threads back to what
the original string representation is
because the reason you want that I mean
sometimes you just want okay give me the
list of comments but often you'll want
to know it relative to the original
string representation so that for
example the front end can have little
arrows that point to those parts of the
string does that make sense yeah
that would be great to have yes okay I
don't know how to do that
okay so I'm making a suggestion here so
what I'm saying is what you should think
about is returning these linty things
this is in a sense merely a decorated
tree so in other words you could imagine
having the complete concrete syntax tree
with everything in it but in the these
payloads here in these sort of head tags
or whatever you would have things that
say oh this subtree has this issue
associated with it
see what I'm saying yeah yeah okay I
thought you meant more visually speaking
no I'm not talking about the visual side
of it that's not that's not the problem
with solving you know the
problem-solving here is a transport
layer that's completely right so then
the idea would be to unify this linting
mechanism with the parse tree mechanism
and to basically say and the token list
mechanism and basically say this is one
of the options for I mean I don't think
that's the only form that this will be
in I think eventually there'll be a
bunch of convenience functions that are
more direct than this but in terms of
thinking about the you know unified
design for the whole thing I think the
right thing to do is to take think about
this parse tree object if you might not
have that name in the end and have you
know one of its formats be something
that either is a you know effectively
and it's in a bad name a linked list so
to speak yeah um or have something which
is a Linton concrete syntax tree yeah
yeah now there is a question of Lintz
problems can span over different nodes
though - and there might be a
representation problem of how do you
avoid needlessly duplicating annotations
across multiple nodes but notice is the
lint annotation a subtree is it does it
annotate a subtree Oh does it annotate
disjoint nodes what we're seeing is what
it does it is annotating the line of the
string you're talking about okay butBut
that's yeah okay fine but what does it
do it the love of the concrete syntax
tree which is where it's presumably
actually living well it's it generates
generating a list of problems it's not a
problem at all what comes out in the
structure of those lint objects for
example has the same source structure
that we saw above you know with line
line and column information but that
line and column
might not directly map but but when
you're generating this stuff it's
happening at the level of the concrete
syntax tree that's where you have the
rules correct yeah yeah yeah right so so
whatever those rules are presumably they
apply to a subtree well okay so I think
I'm on the screen on the left is a good
example if we're talking about both
branches of an if statement right that's
not the entire subtree because I
understand because the sub whole entire
subtree is the thing that you've got
little space indicators underneath it's
the entire if right subtree is the ABB
but I would prefer to only annotate BB
okay I I think that's going to be a
mistake I mean it's it's where the
problem is though I mean there's no no I
I understand that but so what I'm
suggesting is I'm thinking here yeah
yeah the issue is map it directly to the
tree the issue is that once you've said
there are problems on these two sub
branches the question is how do you
connect the problems on those two sub
branches and one question is how many
levels down the tree can that problem
occur and it might in this particular
case it's at one level there's two bad
actors so to speak out of your
collection of three nodes yeah right but
it could be I suspect that the bad actor
is hidden down part two to one on one
branch in part one three four five on
the other branch yeah yeah but that that
you know that the badness is visible I
mean like for example I could imagine
something with are scoping problems in a
pretty big expression there's a variable
that has um you know where it's like for
example the things that turn red in
something like is it obvious example
right where it's pretty pretty you know
distant right yeah so I claim that that
should be annotated at the level of the
scoping construct and that you shouldn't
try to kind of Rhonda
the things you know by saying that part
down at one three five eight or
something is really a you know is
something that is conflictive with the
thing at part position two one that type
of thing I think it's a mistake to try
to have those things wave flags at each
other to say that they're connected sure
I think it's a better idea to go from
the top-level scoping construct and look
at its subtree and say these small sub
parts of its subtree have this connected
issue now the only question would be
when you're down at so so here's that
here's a question so you're analyzing
the tree and let's say you took out a
sub tree and then the question is which
don't think it's obvious what the answer
should be let's say you've got a scoping
conflict okay then and you've extracted
a sub tree a deep shadowing or what do
you man who knows what I mean all kinds
of weird I mean I I you know I can
probably make one up I mean I you know
if I say you know f of X blank colon
equals x plus y plus X blank okay yep
there I've got some weird conflict right
okay so what I'm saying is if you were
to take so this is where there's sort of
inheritance this you this whole thing
clearly as a complete tree there is a
conflict in part whatever that is one
one or something with part whatever it
is two three whatever it is right okay
now let's imagine that you take this
subtree out right that subtree no longer
has a patent conflict so to speak right
it has a latent conflict but it does not
have a an explicit conflict so my claim
is the right thing to do in that case is
that the full conflict descriptor is at
the level of the of the whole tree here
right but this thing that has what's
that delayed yeah yeah yeah yeah right
the set delayed node but that what
happens is that
this contains a shadow of the fact that
there was a conflict now we may
subsequently want to ignore that
conflict because that piece of code
might be pasted into something for which
there's no conflict at all you see what
I'm saying but to to record the fact
that there was a conflict there seems
useful but I don't think that you want
to try to you know have the thing waving
a flag at the other X Bank to say I'm
conflicted with you because who knows
where those things will wind up yeah
once we are talking about things that
can persist yes okay well but look the
point is that we're going to want to do
manipulation on these things and yeah
anyway so that's my suggestion is that
yeah yeah that the the main issue comes
as subtrees that the you know it's a
dirty subtree it's got something wrong
with it now the the sub-elements the
actual individual elements that have a
problem should as an advisory matter
record that they have a problem because
when they are detached they will then
know that they used to have a problem
but many things will choose to ignore
those advisories that make sense yeah I
mean it I mean it turns into a question
of representation and how we do all of
this efficiently well fair enough but I
mean I I don't know how you I would
think that the fundamental thing you're
doing is scuffing advisory data into
these heads right which I don't think
and you know the question how you do
that and how you maintain shared
pointers to things I don't know but
that's I think what it should do user
wise that's what it should appear to be
doing okay so let's let's go back down
here um in terms of what these messages
look like what we need and we will need
that also for the function repository
and so on we need some symbolic
representation of those message blobs
which you know we don't yet I assume
that we have that somewhere in the
system I think we should expose that and
whatever that is we should use that to
be
the thing that is even contained in I
mean I think it reminds me of
interpreter which has a whole mechanism
for I mean because you know interpreter
has multilingual support and God knows
what else for for dealing with error
cases am I making sense
so what interpreter does um yeah I
thought failure object just came back
what's that yeah I mean I just
yes but the important point is that they
contain message tags that can be used
that message tag is used in practice by
the form function to actually give you
what the message should be when the form
is used yeah okay so if you scroll down
on the Left I have a list of possible
names of objects what these can be all
of under the assumption that lint is
probably not the one that's going to
live in oh it's not obvious to me that
this shouldn't just be a failure object
well fine sure I mean maybe it's a
warning object or something I don't know
yeah I mean just the war I mean just the
word failure is what I'm talking about
yeah well I understand that but I think
um you know the difference between a
warning a remark hint an indication of
suggestion these are all shades of
something yes all shades of commentary
basically commentary object yeah
possibly um so I think the most general
what I mean that's yeah go ahead
issue no way no way issue has too many
other meanings of you know issue things
issue forth so to speak well but that's
why we say object well if you meant okay
yeah fine I think that's not the right
thing I think that the better thing
would be something okay so another
metaphor that we have is annotation yeah
and we've used
using annotation now to be something
that is very close to what you're
talking about um it is something where
you've got like an audio string stream
and you want to annotate a part of that
audio stream to say Brenton was talking
at that point yeah or you you can
annotate a graph and I think so here's
an interesting question for our trees
what is the interaction between
annotation construct and our trees I
think this is the place to go with this
not completely sure all the pieces but I
think that's the place to go is to use
the annotation calculus that we already
have because let me point out that there
is a you know this whole question about
what do you keep what do you throw away
that's part of our annotation calculus
for graphs okay so let's imagine that
you've done um you've colored a node
blue and then you find a subgraph okay
okay you probably keep the blueness of
the node let's say that you color a node
blue and then you find a graph
intersection with another graph where
that node isn't colored blue what do you
do see what I'm saying
yeah and the same thing will come up
with these trees that is for example let
me give you an example you would have
something where the X blank
you're comparing let's say you're doing
some Auto grading you're comparing two
expressions and one of them had came
from something where there was an
advisory thing that said this X blank is
probably in the wrong place but by the
time you're looking at the subtree all
is hunky-dory and then the question is
do you keep that annotation do you throw
it away what do you do depends on the
operation you're doing how you treat
that annotation I think this is the
place to go I'm not completely sure of
all the I da ting and T crossing but I
think we've got a whole system and one
of the things that's nice is we've got a
system for inserting annotations which
will be very useful for these porous
trees right because then you can have
analysis code that basically injects
annotations that says you know I think
this piece of code is bad in this place
and so on
I mean as long as it's efficient well
better be because it's being used for
graphs which are big why don't you go
find out how that stuff works this is a
Charles shoddy production yeah yeah okay
I think we've run out of time for this
particular meeting this is really
terrific stuff and I'd like to UM why
don't you do one iteration thinking
about learning about what's been done
with trees learning about what's been
done with annotations
um the it's some and then let's come
back to this and try and do another
another round of design on this sure um
but I'm you know this is really nice and
I think I mean hopefully with the trees
project also being active um these
things can connect well huh all right oh
gosh we're really over time here okay
terrific by the way for people on the
livestream you might be interested to
know on Monday we have another product
suggestions and priorities at 4:00 p.m.
eastern US time um and maybe that one
will be less than three hours
what's the other one three hours that
way I think it was about 240 or
something like that yeah okay well it
was very useful a lot of good
suggestions would appreciate it um okay
sounds good
all right very nice Benton very nice
thank you okay All Right see y'all soon
thanks for comments on the livestream
and there were a few comments there
Brenton you might want to look at